what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chains
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off David Pakman is
currently a partner at bedrock where he
focuses on early stage venture investing
and consumer and enterprise tech
companies with a recent focus on
robotics crypto and consumer products he
also was the co-creator of Apple's music
group and a product manager at Apple
along with starting and selling a number
of technology companies in this
conversation we discussed David's views
on audio and voice artificial
intelligence robotics competition on the
Internet
why crypto can disrupt venture capital
and what is so interesting to David
about the idea of crypto collectables I
really enjoyed this conversation
all right guys bang bang I've got a
David Here I am I'm really excited about
this because I think that you have
probably the best understanding of other
frontier technologies if anyone would
brought in here so we're gonna talk a
lot about crypto but we got other things
to talk about as well so thanks so much
for coming to do this thanks for having
me it's like to be here let's go through
your background I feel like you as a
venture capitalist a lot of people know
especially younger people but you had a
whole life before investing I did I
still feel like I'm a new investor so
let's start from the beginning you
actually were a trained engineer yeah
peer science engineer from Penn brought
a lot of code and then how did you go
from there to all of the music work that
you did well I was always a musician
growing up like drums still do and was
fortunate enough to be born at a time
when the Internet in the 90s was just
becoming commercially adopted and it was
somewhat obvious that print and music
you know audio are gonna be the first
two media types to be affected by
digital distribution right
and so I I started working for Apple
during school and then afterwards I
moved to Cupertino and work for Apple
and I was in the system software product
group I was a product manager and worked
on a couple different operating system
versions and then
saw this collision of sort of music and
internet happening and you know there
was no need for if you can send a song
digitally over the internet you don't
need a CD anymore and so was someone
obvious I think that was gonna happen
and I proposed to Apple that given I
guess my view was tech companies would
be able to function as pieces of the
music industry value chain maybe even
replacing record labels who I viewed
largely as you know unnecessary
middlemen that took too much of the
value still true today
artists deserve more and we should try
to get people as many people out of the
middle as possible and connect artists
with fans it felt like that's what the
Internet could do yeah so I proposed to
Apple that they start a group focused on
exploiting new digital distribution
technologies and trying to build a new
music business yeah the reason I thought
Apple could do it was not only did we
have the technology but we were also Max
had been adopted by most creative
professionals in the world still true
today I mean almost every creative
discipline but especially in music you
know every recording studio had a Mac
back then they still do today every
artist had a Mac so we had a certain
level of credibility I think with
artists so could talk to them about hey
there's this new world coming yeah and
Apple said that's pretty good a pretty
good idea why don't you leave that so
with a couple other people I started the
music group at Apple and we started to
investigate different ways of ushering
in a digital future yeah what was it
like when you first joined Apple so pre
the music group you know I think a lot
of people especially in technology just
there were you know fanboys and fangirls
of this company and the founder etc but
what was it like when you first got
there well I was a fan boy too you know
I saw the Mac when it you know first
came out and said this is amazing in
fact I used a Mac at Penn in an
engineering school doing all my coding I
was the only engineering student who was
using a Mac everyone else was using pcs
I had to find alternate versions of the
tools that everyone was using so it's
pretty rare than
anymore and I love the products I just
believe that you could create complex
technology products that were easy to
use that was Apple's mantra make great
products so I wanted to work for him in
the worst way someone at school I met
was a an Apple student rep Apple hires I
think they still do today like a person
on every college campus and sort of
deputizes them to be like a junior
representative they paid you back then
in gear so I was like that's good enough
for me
so I applied and I got that job and I
got a laser printer I was like the only
kid on campus with a laser printer
that's what I got paid in so um I'd
wanted to work for them I started
working for them in the summers like had
summer internships and then went to
Cupertino for a summer and you know I
was in kid in a candy store what was
amazing about and I eventually got a
full-time job there as soon as I
graduated I moved out to Cupertino what
was amazing was just the quality of the
people I mean it was kind of warped me
in many ways because I was like wow
everyone is much smarter than I am and
knows way more than I do and is you know
determined they're passionate and I
thought every place in the world would
be like that every place is not like
that but it is one of the things that
sets Apple apart and it was an
incredible experience learn from so many
people yeah it's interesting I worked at
Facebook for two years and similarly I
think that's the part that people don't
understand unless you go spend a lot of
time there or work there is the quality
of the people it's almost like that's
what they're focused on hiring right
just the higher high quality people and
like they'll surprise you what they can
actually produce and it sounds like you
would have actually being one of those
people with I don't know if they had
plans ever go into the music industry
right but hey we hired some more people
they come to us with this idea yeah go
do it and then you go execute on it do
you think that companies could be
successful without hiring kind of the
best people right abate this all time
with founders who say you know we need
out we need to fill that role and how
long do you wait to find the right
person versus you need somebody to
execute on it today yeah I think it's um
it's tied to one other concept you can't
just try to hire the best people I think
if to do two things
you got to hire the best people and you
need to empower them and I think that
there's sort of a set of manager
tactics that I would quantify as Silicon
Valley best practices its how tech
companies are built and you working at
Facebook understood this pretty clearly
Apple and Netflix and Amazon and Google
the concept is you push decision-making
down right you try to get teams small so
that innovation is maximized and you
empower them to experiment iterate
propose things you try not to centralize
all decision make you try to
decentralize it you try to put all the
innovation bottoms up and what happens
is we've got great people who are
motivated and you sort of set them on a
direction you get great ideas as opposed
to limiting the number of people who are
allowed to make ideas which is sort of
the legacy way that companies were built
and it's proven to be you know massively
disruptive to the way industries evolve
their you know courses taught there are
consultants that try to teach you know
half the companies we're staring out the
window here looking at in New York City
how to behave differently this way
and so I think that's you got to hire
great people but you also have to
empower them to go be creative and
experiment and I think sort of the core
root of Silicon Valley's advantage is
this great people who are future
oriented who are motivated and
incentivized to disrupt the past and
make things better are allowed to
experiment until they do yeah it's um
it's really interesting to hear you say
it cuz when you hear it it's like yes
that is absolutely what's going on there
is that organizational structure or is
that more cultural or urge there that's
terrible yeah yeah I mean you have to
build the org that way you have to tell
people that's what we want you to do you
have demonstrate over time that that's
the way products evolve and and then you
build an institutional culture around it
but it's very common in tech companies
I'm using the term Silicon Valley
broadly right we do that at New York
companies to do that in Austin yeah but
tech companies have been are being built
this way and have been for 25 years and
it's I think proving to be just a leaner
more nimble decentralized diffuse get
the best out of people focus yeah for
sure we started the Apple music group
this is pre or
post like Napster and kind of all of the
decent rice file-sharing yeah so around
that time there was this thing called
mp3's right and this was like there's
some young kid listening right now
what's an mp3 yeah yeah well so this is
like mid nineties like 95 and I think by
96 or 97 the number one search term on
the internet was mp3 really it was
higher than porn Wow and that's because
it was the only way to get music
digitally was to get to get an mp3 and
Napster came about around that exact
time as a way to make it even more
convenient to get mp3s mp3 was just a
file format for compressing music in
high fidelity it was a format that was
not controlled by the traditional music
business it came out of a German
standard-setting body and it you didn't
need a license to use it as a consumer
he needed a license to put it in a
product a lot of people license it put
it in their products and it became easy
to make mp3s from CDs and it became easy
to play them back and so that was what
was happening in them in the mid-90s so
it was just as Napster was emerging that
I was saying this is this is what's
gonna happen and this is any idea of an
iPod coming down people previous many or
several years before right yeah okay and
so as you started to get into this was
it hey we know exactly we want to go do
or was it just there's Apple kind of our
ecosystem our creativity innovation and
there's music let's go figure it out
like how much was it um did not know
what we wanted to do but we I would say
there were two main thrusts one was we
had a set of technologies called
QuickTime which was really a suite of
audio and video compression and
transport standards so that you could
compress audio and video send them over
wires like networks like Internet and
you could view them on a computer and we
wanted to promulgate those into a lot of
different use cases and entertainment is
an obvious one for that so how do we get
quicktime more adopted well let's go to
musicians who make songs and music
videos and start getting him to use
QuickTime to distribute music and second
I think it was clear that
mp3s we're looking like kind of a mess
to manage whole you start getting a
whole lot of them and you need tools to
manage them and Apple is pretty good at
and user software experiences so maybe
we need software to help people manage
their libraries of mp3s and then you
eventually saw iTunes emerge a tool for
ripping CDs and storing your libraries
and this is all pre streaming so you had
these very large collections of mp3s
yeah it the creatives response to this
right I think today it's become much
more popular to whether you're an
athlete or a celebrity or a musician to
be a tech investor and kind of be
entrepreneurial etc back then maybe like
the hip hop industry etc was
entrepreneurial in terms that they want
to start their own labels and things
like that but what was the reception
when you started talking about more like
hardcore technology you really like
quicktime and mp3 etc was it a good
reception or was there kind of a big
learning curve in education work on your
guys on yeah you'd be surprised that the
the forward-thinking people were the
artists who almost always if you think
about it are the ones who are adopting
technology very early in the cycle so in
the 80s you had all the artists adopt
synthesizers long before you know
traditional music did and what does that
do it created a whole boom of you know
sort of particular style of style of
music or genres drum machines same thing
now thinking back you know things like
auto-tune and different algorithms used
in music creation so artists are very
forward-thinking and love to try the new
thing helps them get a different sound
the laggards were the record companies
who are who at this time and and still
today are largely run by lawyers since
music is really a intellectual property
and so lawyers are by their nature
risk-averse and I'm very control
oriented and so the record labels the
major labels were complete lacquers
about it don't want to hear it don't
wanna meet we're not gonna license any
music in digital formats we like the
control that we have through CDs we want
to prolong this as long as possible
it's like a fear of disruption or just
like a control
it's just control we want to control
and but the independent labels indie
labels because of by also their nature
need to experiment they were willing to
really experiment in the first labels
that were licensing music for use in
digital download we're all Indies mm-hmm
yeah it's it's kind of like the
innovation comes out of necessity right
and and ya willingness to experiment for
sure so you guys obviously start off on
music group it's done amazing things
that many people don't even realize kind
of what you guys are responsible for you
eventually move on and and I think you
would like a private equity firm it
started to buy businesses grow them etc
two things before that is and this is a
very typical path when you go work at
Apple or Facebook or Amazon you might
meet a whole bunch of amazing people and
learn best practices software
development organizational development
how do you hire people but many times
you might choose to take that to a
start-up so most of my mentors that
folks who I I admired and learn from
Horta several years older than I was
that was their path they were at Apple
for a blood draw for a while then they
left and went to startup so I was like
oh I'm gonna do that and so I left Apple
and I went to startup and this was in
the mid 90s I went to a company called
n2k which was on the first digital music
companies and it was trying to sell
digital downloads online really yeah and
we had a CD store online like we buy CDs
but then we were really pressing to try
to sell digital downloads online very
early but the company went public and it
was pretty successful it merged with its
rival CD now and we were an online music
retailer but we were we're also a record
label and the idea was boy if we could
sell enough music online we could sign
artists and then the artists could sell
music directly to their fans and that
was you know probably thirty years too
early but the concept was a good one it
is funny that that was the idea because
there's some people trying to do that
now okay so you do that and then how do
you go from n2k to kind of the creation
of this digital Locker or something yeah
well so the thing that was somewhat
obvious was people have a lot of mp3s
and
and there and there they're storing them
on their local hard drives but the
internet connects everything so what
happens when you leave your house and
you get to work and you want to listen
to some music
all your musics back home on your hard
drive what doesn't make any sense right
so let's move the music off your local
hard drives to up to the cloud and we
started a service to do exactly that it
was called my Play you could think of it
as Dropbox for music and one of the cool
things was once you uploaded your songs
you didn't have to download them again
you could stream them now it was super
choppy bandwidth at this point so it
wasn't the most reliable thing and a lot
of people had you know modems at home
which weren't high enough bandwidth so
it wasn't a great consumer experience
but you could see it being the beginning
of what's streaming music would become
certainly more convenient than you know
carrying a hard drive around and that
company was called my play and we got to
about eight million users and we sold
that one to bertelsmann who you know
it's BMG music yeah it's funny because I
remember being a young kid and everyone
was running around with you'd get in
someone's car and basically the way you
could tell if somebody was cool or not
was what CDs they had in their CD case
right and that was kind of the rather
than care I'm the hard drive you
literally cater on a CD case and you
know god forbid you forgot it at home or
you left it in your friend's car or
whatever you had no music right yeah and
so a similar thing there got into as
you're building that I think there's a
lot of comparisons that sounds like to
where kind of crypto is today and we'll
get into crypto stuff but what was the
thought process as you guys are building
a service that you know it's not perfect
right and kind of you're at the
beginning of hey this is gonna improve
over time there'll be better streaming
the technology that the consumer has
will improve etc but somebody has to be
those first steps down that path right
are you kind of aware of it at the time
is there frustration of man we wish that
we could technically solve this or do
you understand hey we're early to this
and you know it's just gonna take some
time to improve it's a really
interesting question Anthony because I I
was young then and
I felt I felt I feel like today that
those years I was very certain of where
the world was gonna go I was absolutely
convinced that music would become
streaming music that all music would go
digital that you know CDs work doomed
that artists could take back some
control have direct relationships with
their customers at least know who their
fans are no idea who they were otherwise
and and bandwidth would improve like
that it was just so obvious to me that
digital connection was so much better
than waiting for a newspaper to arrive
every morning right or having to go put
a CD in a truck like you know but we
called it Adams to bits right that was
so obvious to me so I don't think we we
were probably more impatient right like
why come on to these damn phone
companies they're so slow at rolling out
higher bandwidth connections because it
will enable such great experiences for
consumers so we had to compromise like
we had to make websites that could load
on slow connections and we had to do
some kind of cross sampling or down
sampling for high fidelity tracks so
that they could stream over lower
bandwidth connections and you don't do
that as much anymore so I think we just
tried to accommodate we were certainly
early I think your point is this is you
know 1997 1998 1999
no one has broadband at their home yet
you know we didn't have Wireless high
high bandwidth connections so you
couldn't do this to your phone yet but
we were right we were early that's all
yeah it's like the was the ringtones was
like a big deal I think that's like some
of the first digital music I remember
interacting with but but it's
interesting because a good friend of
mine constantly says that you know the
best entrepreneurs or short-term urgent
long-term patient yeah right and I think
that it's kind of a perfect example of I
mean still today right that they're
still streaming improvements going on
etc and we're talking you know 20 plus
years later so also I think it's
relevant to the crypto conversation
we'll get to I guess soon because I
think a lot of people in crypto are
certainly certain that the world is
going to be more decentralized and that
institutions will continue to erode and
so we need to digitize trust but but
none of us know exactly when that goes
mainstream in the same way that you know
digital music was certain to me we just
didn't know when it would tip and become
mainstream got it when did you want to
become an investor like what was the
jump from building companies you have
see had success kind of being innovative
and entrepreneurial inside of Apple then
a number of companies yourself like what
was the yeah going back to Apple a lot
of my mentors you know stated Apple five
or ten years left there did a start-up
or two or three and then became PCs like
that was the path and I was like well
that seems pretty cool I like the idea
of helping entrepreneurs once you've
been a good one and I like the idea of
learning about more than one area so
what the real moment for me was after
spending fifteen years as a digital
music entrepreneur you know I did and 2k
CD now I did my play and I teamed up
with some guys and bought a music and
ran that for five years it was like you
know there's got to be more to life than
digital music right and mobile was
starting to emerge and social was
starting to emerge and I said I want to
get smarter about these other markets
and by the way they feel like they're
much bigger like there's way more
opportunity there I want to play in the
where the big fish are swim with the
whenever I want to fish were the big
fish are and and that was really the
motivation for maybe trying to become a
B C and I was fortunate enough to find a
firm that was looking for somebody like
me got it
did you know what else you wanted to
look at or was it just outside of
digital music there's a whole bunch of
other areas I want to go help
entrepreneurs in those areas I'll figure
it out when I get there
I've sort of been long internet since
1995 right like it was like this is
gonna this just changes absolutely
everything like it literally takes the
value proposition or the value chain of
every industry and throws it up in the
air and it's all going to resettle
totally differently and we're still I
don't know what percentage we are into
that but think about the conversations
you have with fin tech entrepreneurs who
are like reorganizing the insurance
sector right or we re or
the way it homes our spot and sold or
the way appraisals are done like we're
we're so far into just reorganizing
everything thanks to the internet and
software that I just knew that we have
an infinite amount of opportunity and I
didn't have a specific agenda but for me
the big one was mobile was happening at
the time it was like this is smart
phones gonna change everything
once again we're gonna reorient a lot of
pieces everything has to be rebuilt for
mobile yeah
and it's crazy too because it's still
happening right I mean I see companies
all the time getting started that I'm
like wow that's a really good idea can't
believe that the internet hasn't touched
that corner of the world yet and you
know good bet for you to be long
internet this is 95 but you know 25
years later still still happening yeah
and I think what your as an entrepreneur
you usually want to ride a wave right
because rising tide lifts all boats and
and you get credit for something that's
pushing you along I remember like I mean
one of the ways that YouTube got big was
they did an an embed code that's sitting
on top of my space my space was big and
that helped make youtube go and and so
there's countless examples of like
companies you know Zynga that rode the
Facebook wave you're always looking for
a wave and mobile was a way of social
was a wave there's a question it's not
only we know enough yet you know is a IO
wave and it's crypto a wave right and
and when when you have waves that are
really big you might argue cloud was a
wave too right reorganize the entire
sort of infrastructure stack and
corporate software enterprice offer if
crypto is gonna be a wave than a whole
lot of things are gonna get reoriented
as well and and that's I think what many
of us why many of us are poking around
there yeah so some of the things outside
of crypto you're focused on right at
Venrock is kind of audio and voice AI
special XR around software development
robotics etc maybe let's go through each
one of those before we get to the crypto
stuff what's the kind of belief or or
your view today of like audio and voice
right well why is that so important and
kind of why are you spending time there
yeah well I'm spending a little bit less
time there ok yes like I think that we
went when you started to see these
devices proliferate so this is like the
home devices let's call it serious a
software device
right and you know the echos and Alexa
as a hardware device the question many
of us asked right away was who is this a
new platform will you see audio apps
like you saw apps on mobile and will we
have you know Cambrian explosion of lots
of new products that are built for voice
and you know we didn't know the answer
at the time but over time it started to
become clear that actually this feels a
little bit more like an and not a nor
like you're adding voice to apps like a
feature but it doesn't replace the last
mechanism for interaction so I think the
place that voice has been most impactful
is in podcasting where a very low cost
to produce content and look it's many
cases podcasting is better than radio
right and it's way more variety you lots
of convenient targeting here's a cool
way to think about it I've read a Pew
Research report on why Netflix is
popular so I surveyed tens of thousands
people and said why do you like Netflix
number one two and three answers are one
it doesn't have commercials - I can
watch whatever what I want to watch when
I want to watch and three I can binge
watch it Oh interesting
number four was I like the shows so the
first three reasons why Netflix is
popular is because it's better than TV
yeah if format yeah it just exactly the
format corrects the annoying things of
television of linear television so first
thing you learn about that is if you are
trying to compete with Netflix like your
legacy guys don't do things like we're
dropping an episode once a week like
that's not why people are going to
Netflix they're going one of the reasons
they're gonna fix is because they can
binge so don't try to exercise control
like you did in the legacy world but by
the way not everyone's doing that yeah
so then you in Turner but yeah basically
what they're doing there it sounds like
is the legacy guys realize hey there's
disruption happening and rather than
fully commit or burn the boats instead
what you do is you almost okay we're
gonna go do this but we're still gonna
do it in a way where we're fighting the
headwind of the consumer trend really
and you know what it doesn't work
because the yeah what I think most
legacy media companies still don't fully
get is the consumers in control but the
consumer has infinite choice and just
votes with our eyeballs and then go
somewhere else right so if you make it
high friction or you are substandard
experience compared to the competitors
you just lose their attention right so
Netflix wins on the attention right yeah
the thing that is really interesting to
me about the I'll call kind of the video
platform Wars if you will or whatever
you want to call it is it used to be a
thing where the studio created content
that content was pretty much they were
programming for you literally called it
programming the platforms either they
actually owned that platform or they had
a very significant say because they were
the ones providing the content I'm a lot
of competition now what you're seeing is
there was these aggregation platforms
like prime or Netflix they've then used
that data and they realize it's all
about the quality content well let's
just cut out these studios and we'll go
sink billions of dollars of our own
capital into actually creating originals
and I gotta say like it's pretty high
quality stuff right horse look it's some
they have the data they know what the
customer wants why don't we inform
ourselves what customers want and then
go pay people to make that you know what
one thing I've said before is that guys
who deliver entertainment over the
Internet can buy programming just like
people who deliver entertainment over a
coaxial cable on cable television right
I mean it's they're all just buying
content from creators the creators are
the show writers of show runners and the
actors the directors the editors those
are the creators and they had a month at
the studio's had basically a monopoly on
buying from them because no one else was
buying from them but now all the
internet companies are buying from them
do the same thing their money is just as
good that they can at least inform
themselves with data what's gonna work
so to get back to audio I think if you
think about podcasts they're kind of
better than radio why on demand no
commercials or at least more tolerant
amount of interruptive ads or no
interruptive ads at all maybe an extra
sponsor read it's a little bit more like
public radio that way
but I can listen what I want and I can
binge-watch
right and so I feel like um podcasting
one of the reasons for its success is
its catering to the consumer just a
better product
yeah and radio and that's one of the
reasons for it it's funny because like
content we know higher quality content
normally wins right if the consumer
likes it they'll figure out though jump
through hurdles to go get that quality
kind of motion I'm not so sure it's
always true okay why depends what you
need mean by quality a lot of times
convenience can trump quality but I
think we're using quality differently
I'll just give you one example
music listened to through earbuds yes in
a mp3 format is lower fidelity then like
something coming off a CD but I don't
think that's what you meant by quality
right I like if I like summer
yeah if I like one band over another
yeah I will go and find that band yeah
it's harder for me to write so agreed
the the content in terms of I like it
first I don't yeah but that also brings
up quality of the format right and so if
you think of one of the things I mean
from a personal experience we do an ad
rate at the beginning of each episode
after the introduction advertisers want
you to do them during the episode and
there's people who do it I personally
hate when I listen to something and it
gets broken up by hat so I just refused
to do it and I always joke that like you
actually probably can make more money by
doing it but who are you optimizing for
right who's kind of the customer and I
think that a lot of these platforms have
figured that out yeah so I think in
voice my view is the the the biggest
beneficiary other than the platforms
themselves like Google and Amazon is
this audio programming right and because
it's effectively going after radio yeah
ai so you uh are pretty bullish it
sounds like and and have some very
specific views there maybe just
generally like how do you think of
artificial intelligence and where we are
and then we can get or something like
the software developers
yeah well there's just no doubt that it
is a significant change to the way we
build software and the capabilities that
software can achieve made possible by
processing very large sets of data and
having computers make some decisions
that are and that when their computers
are better at making decisions and
humans are so I think we've been looking
at two main applications of that that
are interesting from the venture
perspective one is well businesses
enterprises make a lot of decisions
every day should I hire this person
should I promote this person where
should my sales teams spend their time
today who should they call what should I
put on my website what should I put in
my email and how should i merchandise my
products where should I sell them
how should I price them on and on how
much inventory should I make how many
different styles should I make these are
questions that businesses have been
asking and answering for you know scores
of years but it turns out that humans
are pretty bad at making almost all of
those decisions given enough data and
tuned algorithms computers can make
better decisions than the humans can so
you're really going after human
decision-making in enterprises and
trying to improve it using data and that
thrust is an investment area matters
it's you know some people call it smart
software or AI for the enterprise we're
just you know
suffer that improves decision-making and
enterprises on a lotta different
dimension now to me that is it's less
revolutionary it's more of an evolution
because you know 20 30 years ago there
were people who just made decisions you
know I always things like the madman you
know what I put on the website let me
lick my finger stick it in the air and
you know I think this is the logo right
or this is the motto over time the
people who have been the most disruptive
or innovative said well let's look at
the data right who clicked on the most
on that button right that type of stuff
but it's still human analyzing the data
what you're really talking about is why
don't we give the data to somebody who's
even better than you I think he's put
the computer in there and take the human
out yep so that's happening I agree with
you you can you can draw it the way you
just drew it and it looks evolutionary
and it kind of is like it's just putting
more faith in the algorithms if you will
but what is different is the process by
which you gather data label it train the
computers and then firm the algorithms
is kind of a break from
a more traditional way that software was
built and it requires a bunch of let's
call it our T's '''l expertise today to
do really well and there's you know tens
of thousands of people maybe a hundred
thousand people in the world who know
how to do it really well
and probably 80% of them work for Apple
Facebook Google and Amazon mm-hmm some
at Netflix and you know a couple more
tech companies right
Microsoft LinkedIn but very quickly you
realize that over the last seven or
eight years the tech giant's have tried
to monopolize the talent on this which
just means that they're both advancing
the state of the art and applying it in
more ways and better than a lot of other
legacy companies can so it's created a
bit of an unfair advantage and that I
think is what opens the opportunity to
sell AI enabled products to enterprises
who can't hire the same talent and and
use their own data to improve for sure
how much of what you guys are seeing in
this space is what I'll call like the
value being placed on the decision
making itself versus more like testing
frameworks in the data gathering right
the example I always think back is when
I joined Facebook I was running a team
that was focused on growth for Facebook
pages and one of the things that just
blew my mind was they had built custom
software internally where you could
basically feed a bunch of variables into
it it would show all the different
variable combinations to traffic and
kick out you know a couple days later
hey this is the best combination that
would have taken you know 10 humans in a
room 5 days to just come up with all the
different combinations let alone run it
and so to me that was less like the
computer was making the decision if you
will but it was more of using that
testing framework and being able to
actually assign in a pretty scientific
and methodical way get an answer so less
AI but more like testing frameworks yeah
so I think maybe the question you're
asking is that are there investment
opportunities around tools and the stack
used to build AI applications and I
think there are there are
the place that we've been skeptics Oh so
yes you need to gather large sets of
data you need to clean the data you need
to label the data you need to build
models you need to tune the models
sometimes the models should maybe be
tuned like everyday so you need auto
tuning models and you need to make the
models run on low power and sit at the
edge in many cases this is another
specialty have small footprint optimized
models so all these are things that a
bunch of humans are good at and a bunch
of tools are being built to scale and
there are some investment opportunities
there the one place we've been sort of
skeptical is AI as a service very likely
okay so like hi I'm a web site with a
bunch of really smart AI people who work
here and you are we're staring out at
MetLife an insurance company and you
want to upload we have a service where
you can upload all of your data let's
say you can upload all of your claims
and and all of your customer information
and we'll build a model and it'll run
and it'll come back and tell you which
one of your customers are likely to file
claims in the next year
got it I also outsource yeah on the
model as a service we're a little
skeptical that you can genera size AI
that way that it turns out that most AI
problems require a lot of customization
on their solution to make it perform
really well and so it's hard to be a
generic platform is that a and this is a
little bit in the weeds but is that a
problem where the contributor of the
data you've got a lot of worries about
did they collect it correctly clean it
label it etc and so kind of the inputs
to the algorithm could be bad therefore
you get a bad output or is it just
really hard to customize actual
algorithm to the problem I think it's
more the latter yeah it's I mean it's
not rocket science to figure out how to
clean and label data not even a lot of
people crying but but I think that the
bigger issue is do you have the sort of
artisanal knowledge to you to know which
combination of models and algorithms and
machine learning approaches will produce
the best outcome got it and maybe talk a
little bit about AI and kind of software
development we were talking before we
serve recording and if they have a
really interesting view of how software
development might you know materially
change as AI becomes a more mature yeah
so right now I think from a
standpoint AI is being used as a feature
in a lot of software so I mean obviously
your voice assistant is using a lot of
AI to understand what words you're
saying and then understand the meaning
of those words Google photos and an
Apple photos are using a bunch of
IntelliJ miles ai models to do facial
recognition and and find where your dog
is in every picture there's no human
doing all that and those are features
that we're getting very used to today so
you could think of those really as being
traditional software applications with
an AI model sitting in the middle but if
taken to an extreme there suffer
developers when they make software make
a lot of choices like what we were
talking earlier what items should I put
in the menu and what order should those
items be in well a long time ago figured
out well shouldn't the data tell us what
order the items should be and I remember
an example way back like 1999 or
something HP announced we looked at our
website logs and the number one reason
people were coming to the HP website was
to Stan load the drivers for their
printer so we put that button on the
homepage and everyone's like oh my gosh
that's so smart now a consumer can get
right to it
let me go look at my weblog let me look
at my logs so then a bunch of tools
started coming out to analyze your logs
but it still is like tools analyze logs
human reads logs human programmer
changes website then we went into this
era of personalization right in the 90s
where it's like well wait a second why
don't we just write a little algorithm
that says look through logs find five
most popular things for this person and
build the menu that way so that's what
we have today the well we have more than
that today but most websites are
personalizing the experience somehow
putting merchandising products on the
homepage that are right for you yes
sim simple things are you're in the
United States for somewhere else show an
English website though anything else
right yeah more complexes have we have
your purchase history yeah we know you
like sushi so let's show you the food
delivery for sushi yeah but suppose you
took everyone's data who comes to your
website
and every version of the website you've
tried and you threw that all into a
model and use and you gave the computer
a whole lot of other information like
the time of day and the weather in the
area where the customer is coming from
and the computer looked for correlations
that when you when it's cold out and you
live in Duluth Minnesota and you have
this purchase history and you come here
I should show you this parka and while
that's personalization it's it may be
building the rule itself rather than a
human deciding on what the rule should
be and that's machine learning so we're
at that era now where in software
development you may be best to remove
the actual algorithms that a human wrote
and instead let the computer build the
model but the computer build the
algorithm to decide what should be shown
or how to build and what features should
be may show and trend to the customer
and if you if that happens if that
really is true then software development
changes because it your software looks
like really just like one AI model
talking to another am I'll talk to
another game model and there's not a lot
of tools to handle that a couple
companies that are doing that so I think
maybe software development itself could
be implicated on a broad scale because
of this change yeah and as you think
through that it's almost to an extent
your time the computer hey we don't
really know exactly all the questions
you should ask right so you ask what you
think you should ask to get to these
answers and so it brings two questions
one is now you're really reliant on the
human telling the Machine what to
optimize for right so are you optimizing
for purchases right you know one of my
favorite examples is take a media
company they want to optimize for as
much time on-site as possible that means
you're reading a lot of articles and you
know looking at their ads they make more
money
well Google actually optimizes for the
exact opposite thing right is how do I
get you on the search page and you click
the first result and get on couch and so
humans have to understand what they're
optimizing for the second thing it
brings into question is like the
downside of AI right are kind of the
fear I'll call a name of the downside
where what if the machines you know go
off a cliff and they start writing all
these algorithms and you know the
Facebook example I think is the best one
where it was like oh they were talking
to each other maybe right kind of honey
how do you think about you know humans
telling me she's what
optimize for and making sure you get
that right and then also how do you kind
of prevent the the doomsday scenario
that it's probably overhyped a little
bit I like that you asked the question
because Facebook and Twitter already are
using a I created algorithms to decide
which tweet or which post to show you
and it's really good because you ever
catch yourself just sitting there
mindlessly scrolling and that's exactly
what it's built to do that's the KPI
that's the objective function is to keep
you on as long as possible right
engagement and time spent and it's
working and they're very good at it
they're really good at it and I think as
a result of that we're starting to wake
up to that a lot of people are saying
wait a second they're manipulating me
right or I don't want to be mindlessly
scrolling and I'm having a hard time
stopping and that's because like they
know the psychology of the dopamine hit
you get from seeing yourself mentioned
or someone liking so it's all built it's
all it is manipulating us it's just
sixteen oh it's going to our base
behaviors and keeping us on their
website longer and and some people are
starting wake up say I don't think
that's good so what we're gonna do about
that you're going even so that's today
like that is happening today you're
going and farther as like ken can the
software start to do bad things to us
that it's masters didn't ask it to do we
start to get into a philosophical
conversation here but the the distance
from where we are now to like computers
deciding to behave badly versus them
doing exactly what they were asked to do
but it's you know some unintentional
consequences I'm you know we're just
nowhere near general intelligence
artificial general intelligence and I'm
of the mind I'm a computer scientist but
but I'm not a data scientist site I
didn't study AI in school but I'm still
of the mind that you know the smartest
people in the room tell me that we're
just nowhere near that right and when
you see how long it takes to get some of
these algorithms to and to just do very
basic things you realize that they're
not smart in the you know they're not
intelligence in the human sense I always
go back to this idea of it seems like a
lot and you're much more educated on
this than I am
but from an elementary view it's like
look the machines were just doing what
the humans would do if we could write
which is basically taking a bunch of
information processing
better decisions make a decision what
they're not doing is overlaying that
with the one thing that humans are
better at the machines which is the
human intuition and kind of all of the
the general intelligence etc what that
leads me to is I've had this idea for a
long time that let's just you know kind
of admit the machines are continue to
get better and better and better and
eventually humans will trust those
machines and software over other humans
right but if you flip that back to what
we're talking with audio side it's
almost as if all of a sudden the
creativity that general intelligence
will become more valuable in the future
because the repetitive type tasks and
decision making accept the machines will
kind of have a monopoly on that well
what can the machines not do right and
so whether that's content creation my
I've recently met a guy who he's rolling
up ad agencies and his whole idea is
look there's everyone focus on how do
you get more people to click on the
Facebook ad but there's still this niche
of well you need somebody to come up
with the ad campaign right and so his
whole idea is that creativity will
become more valuable over time etc do
you buy into that or do you think that
the machines can eventually evolve from
just the repetitive task to they
literally will create content and things
like that that are just optimized what
we want to see today I think when we
look at the application of machine
learning towards creative things like
visual storytelling or writing text
write or even music creation because
there have been a lot of applications
people trying that stuff they most of
the stuff is interesting but derivative
because no surprise you feed it a lot of
Mozart it's you know spits out something
that sounds strikingly like Mozart
that's amazing in and of itself but when
you think of like well artistry be
subsumed by the computers I think two
things two reasons why it probably won't
be for a very long time one is I think
when you look back at the great artists
and I use that term super broadly in all
forms and all media they were initially
doing something that was a significant
break from the past and may even be
heresy right like this is this is what
is this like I don't understand this
this is terrible does this on anything
like what other people are doing doesn't
look anything like the other people
doing and yet it's that
that that break that is the
demonstration of their genius it's there
it's a it's original thought right it's
something new and that's what can be
that indicator that something great is
happening and it takes time for the rest
of us to catch up and say wait a second
that is really great and even though
though it's different that's one of the
reasons it makes it so great so number
one is I don't I don't know that we're
gonna be able to just tweak the
algorithms and say yeah I fed you all
the Mozart but now do something
completely original yeah the second is I
think we as humans like to understand
the humanity behind the Creator what
story led them to do this and we can
make up a story about a computer that
did something or pretend it wasn't a
computer but boy I think we like to
attach what is the billy Eilish
backstory about why you know employment
and and now I really appreciate our
music even more right so and we're
fascinated by that and that's never
going away so I guess I'm skeptical that
like all the great moments in arts
broadly will now be done by computers
however there's a lot of fields where
let's just call it derivative art won't
be humans won't need to do any more so
like production music background music
what music do you put on the bed of a
commercial or boy you know that's that
can that will be able to be created by
computer it already is animation like I
drew all the main characters and the
cell and the main cells now fill it all
in computer really good at that stuff so
I think there it does impact human
creativity but not in the dramatic way
like okay we're never gonna have another
great author again there'll be no more
Hemingway's yeah absolutely so we talked
a lot about kind of automation in the
software world what about in the
hardware world and brown like robotic
stuff I know you guys I spend a lot of
time there what's kind of going on there
and what you guys excited about what's
interesting is the macros so we've
basically at full employment in this
country and we have rising labor costs
you know hopefully get into $15 an hour
everywhere but then it doesn't stop
there keeps going up and so we have
people who employ humans who need a
bunch of different jobs done that at $15
an hour or more start to become
economically not possible to do
right you hear about farm labor the
labor costs going up such that you they
can't a farmer can't afford to produce
food for us profitably you hear a lot
about like warehouse type jobs you know
highly repetitive low-skilled labor
where if the cop if labor costs keep
going up we won't be able to profitably
produce different goods and that's why
they've those goods have been moving
overseas to be produced so one answer to
that is automation and the thing I want
to stress in we've looked pretty closely
at these many of these markets usually
it's not it's ohms never displacing
human labor the humans are going doing
something else that's slightly less
repetitive something interesting right
that because the higher wage jobs are
for jobs that humans are good at and
that computers and robots aren't that
good at we have a company called Simbi
robotics cindy CS mvsim be the problem
they solve is like literally half a
trillion dollars every year is lost to
you going into a store and the item not
being on the shelf okay five hundred
billion dollar problem Wow the items
often in the store it's just not on the
Shelf it's in the back somewhere where
it's coming in a few hours but it's not
there and another half a trillion
dollars is lost to an item being
mispriced we're not being displayed
properly so we chalk all that up to
human error yeah okay it's it's humans
either Jenny thurr not being good at
that or just being like perennially
bored at it like who wants to walk up
and down store shelves every couple
hours and see what's missing from the
shelves right or what's not displayed
correctly humans hate that job and that
job is often unfilled in many groceries
and retails first because of that no one
wants to do the job high turnover so
this robot does that drives up and down
store aisles finds all the things that
are out does it a couple of times a day
since a text message to the store
manager you're out of mayo on aisle
three position seven or the items in you
know aisle four its position seven are
not displayed according to the planogram
so it doesn't actually quote-unquote fix
the problem it just identifies the
problem maybe the future can fix
whatever but right now it's just an
interface between I'll do a job that the
humans don't want to do I'm really
accurate at it I basically can then
alert the humans and humans will come
fix the problem yep I don't get tired I
do it all day long I don't complain yeah
I'll do it at nighttime - it's a
automated counting machine right and you
like computer vision or pewter visions
got a lot of sensors on it I mean it's
got to know how to drive around can't
hit people can't run over kids and it
shouldn't bang in the car it's got to
avoid spills you've got to be able to
function in the dark like a lot of stuff
and it says pretty sophisticated robot
but that's really well and it really
solves his problem brilliantly yeah and
what's happening is retailers are not
firing the labor who used to do that the
labor doesn't want to do that job they
go do something more useful like
interact with customers to your point
what humans are good at yeah
and into take that system for example if
I'm a grocer I want to use this do I
have to like retrofit my entire store
with sensors on the ceilings and all
this kind of or is it no that's cool
about this company actually it's what
part of the investment pieces is you
literally plug it in yeah it's got a
little self charging pad you got to set
up a little area in the corner of the
store and it's got to integrate with
your inventory management system so it
knows it can tell you like this SKU is
missing but it drives up and down for a
day or two Orient's itself builds a map
and then you tell it how often you want
it to run and it works so it's meant to
to solve the problem without you needing
to retrofit at all yeah it kind of
operates in the environment the way
humans did yeah it's pretty interesting
what's your thoughts on on these like
Amazon go stores and what I'll call kind
of the the ultimate culmination of a lot
of the different things we're talking
about here where it's software computer
vision and robotics etc how do you see
that kind of place yeah so that
eliminates the cashier experience and
and the first time you went to an Apple
store and like you didn't have to go
stand in line for a cashier you were
like well that's a better experience
right this is even better than that
right because you don't have to find the
person in the store your sleeve so I
think that's a great you know going back
to the Netflix example that is a better
version of retailing than legacy
retailing so yeah we're gonna do more of
that but that requires a really major
retrofit and a big expense
so this
solves a interesting set of problems
without requiring like you got to build
a store very differently so I think for
instance I think Cindy would be adopted
what is being adopted way more quickly
then let's rebuild the store to be
cashier less although that's happening -
I think just much more slowly yes it so
broadly I think we're looking at a lot
of robotic solutions that do the jobs
that humans don't want to do or aren't
very good at so you can lower the cost
of production and humans can be deployed
to do better things I am I forget the
exact stat so no one tweeted me and tell
me I got it wrong but it was something
like maybe 200 years ago or something it
was like 80% of people were farmers
right what you know some long period of
time ago a majority of humans worked on
farm and it's because we need food to
live etcetera as quote unquote
automation or technology get
incorporated so literally just a tractor
or things like that those humans didn't
all of a sudden you know die off because
of starvation or not having a living
they wouldn't did other things that
you're saying and so this happens kind
of you know periodically in these
technology shifts and it's interesting
to see I think it's happening to more
white-collar employees then probably
previously but it's also still happening
in you know a grocery store or elsewhere
and I actually believe that the white
collar populations are not expecting it
whereas I think you know you talk to a
truck driver talk to you like they know
this stuff's coming and so they're kind
of quote-unquote prepared the way color
folks I don't think are nearly as esther
yeah so I think broadly we agree with
your point of view that something like
you know 30 to 45 percent of all jobs
are automatable and that's the 30 to 45
yeah it's a pretty big number if today's
jobs yeah some are blue collar and some
are white collar and the over the course
of 20 or 30 years and so it doesn't mean
that it will they'll all be automated
over that of course the time but but
they're the job function itself was
likely can be automated again I think
that history shows us that just that
doesn't throw a lot of people in
unemployment
it makes systems more productive and
lets humans move on to higher order
tasks so I am confident that over the
long term it's a good thing it can
create a bunch of economic disruption
during the transition
which can be pretty painful and I think
we're or destined to experience some of
that some political candidates recognize
that they're talking about it a lot and
some some ignore it but it is a
potentially societal issue but it is
inevitable because the the march of
technology is is largely unstoppable I
mean look well here's a good example
that most people read in the New York
Times over the weekend about this
company Clearview AI which is doing
something with facial recognition that
has been possible for a number of years
but Google Amazon Facebook chose not to
do for those they don't know essentially
in an over generalized manner if there's
a photo of an individual whether whoever
has it they can essentially put it into
this system and this system will then go
match it to photos all over the internet
and come back with here's all of the
data associated with these photos so you
can find people's names their locations
you know information that actually when
I read the article I was kind of like
well duh most of you people put that
information on the internet anyways the
computer's just being able to find it
better but obviously you know if you
look at it from like a law enforcement
standpoint the the fear-mongering
scenario is at a pattern of somebody on
the sidewalk and next thing I know I
know where they live right and I don't
like that system because this feels more
like a surveillance state yeah a
government that doesn't like people who
are peacefully protesting outside can
take pictures of everyone find out
exactly who they were and have the IRS
audit them right without you realizing
that it all happened I mean they're a
bunch of scary scenarios that happen
Mike my point in bringing it up was a
lot of people possessed the technology
to do this for a number of years and
chose not to until one entrepreneur came
along and chose to do it
and so that's my point about like when
it becomes possible it will happen yeah
do you think it's bad not necessary that
specific scenario but just do you think
it's bad when some companies have the
technology they choose not to pursue
something for whether it's ethical
reasons just not good for their business
but their opportunity costs whatever and
then somebody comes along and does it or
do you think of it it's less good or bad
it's just kind of that's how technology
progresses I view the march of
technology is inexorable and you know
it's like cloning right like of course
China was going to do
right so somebody was yeah right right
so someone will do it whatever
technology is possible someone will do
it so that leaves you with two choices
you can legislate this is where
governments come in and you set a hard
and fast rules about what society will
accept and what it won't or you try a
more delicate approach in getting
responsible companies to self-police
right and there are examples of that
that work both of those approaches
working and they're examples of both of
those approaches failing this is a
debate the society should have I think
most of the you're hearing this now I
mean like um CEO of Google just said
last week like we we are seeking
legislation from the government on AI
that is basically him saying the
government and society should decide
what are the limits of AI because we
don't want to be the arbiter and we will
adhere to the laws but the government
should set the laws yeah it's um this is
happening a lot of different aspects of
intersection of kind of society and
technology rates censorship I think is
the easiest one I actually don't have a
view because I've spent enough time
thinking about it but one of the most
interesting debates that seems to be
kind of percolating now with the u.s.
presidential election coming up is
should platforms have a say in what
political ads are running or not run so
everything from accuracy to just should
we have put a class should we not and it
seems like each platform is kind of
taking a different approach and you know
given the in light of 2016 and kind of
all the accusations from every nation
state in the world about each other you
just get into this weird world of like
one who do you trust right in terms of
the information and then to like who
should be making those decisions and I
look there's 330 million people in
United States I don't think you're gonna
call with an answer that everyone agrees
on right and so this is gonna take us to
crypto because really I you see my
leader I mean this is the root of why a
lot of people are excited about crypto
is that what what happened in the arc
that we just discussed from 1995 until
2019 um we the Internet enabled
incredible things everything did went
digital
every
it can move around the world we've wired
it the world wouldn't on three and a
half billion people we're gonna get the
rest of them on the Internet as well
everyone's connected it'll lower the
costs of publishing freedom of
expression not in all countries but in
many it democratized access to a lot of
information and and it did two other
things that are the sort of unintended
consequences or at least consequences
that maybe not everyone foresaw one it
allowed for manipulation because if the
costs of producing information is really
inexpensive and access is free then you
can put out none information firm ation
right and people are doing that and
guess what that's working and - they
don't I think we didn't really foresee
is that the new platforms would combine
data with access and the data would
become centralized and powerful and so
now we democratized access with the
internet but what what crypto I think
hopes for many of us think about as web
3 is can we democratize data so no one
can have a monopoly on your data and so
you sit inside of you know one of kind
of the the most respected venture
capital firms in America right and you
guys are investing in all kinds of
different industries and maybe we just
talked about why pay attention to crypto
right is it a thing where hey we see
opportunities to make money and our job
is to take out peace capital and go make
money is it this is gonna touch
everything and so we gotta pay attention
to it is it personal interest like like
when you guys first start to look at it
I don't think there was a lot of venture
capital firms that were like you know
I'm starting a venture capital firm
focuses on crypto I think it's naturally
been this progression so what drew you
guys into it well for real we are
followers we are looking for where where
is the future going irrespective of what
we decide to do and we want to be on
that path and what we're looking for are
waves that are not just small changes in
the future but big ones that can
disrupt legacy industries and reorder
value chains and be vectors themselves
for progress so we've seen a lot of
those in my life I've seen a bunch of
them right it's all sort of personal
computers that's all
internet I saw a mobile social and cloud
and now we might be on the cusp of
seeing another AI not clear if that's
gonna be a wave or really a sort of
evolution augmentation right it's
definitely something and there's good
debates on both sides and crypto right
decentralization do you have more
confidence in AI being a wave or crypto
or do you not look at it as a
comparative I don't know I never heard
stacked one against the other I'm
investing in both what I say I don't
know it I don't know like I mean really
my human brain is not capable of
predicting and so I'm looking for a
signal in AI I think we are seeing very
strong signal that it it makes highly
more performant software it whereas in
humans it works and so it's gonna be
applied everywhere does that reorder
markets is an unknown question and we're
watching a couple indicators that's true
or not or is it just everyone gets good
at that just like everyone got good at
cloud yeah with crypto I feel like it is
such a departure both soft from a
software architecture perspective the
way you build things and from a
philosophical perspective and the last
time we saw as big a philosophical
change as sort of web 3 was a really
open source and there's sort of this
Fred Wilson calls it Internet Ness right
there's the there was this almost
culture among the people not almost
there was a culture among early pioneers
of distributed networks of the ARPANET
and and the Internet that information
should be more democratized and we
should remove gatekeepers and everyone
should have the power to publish and
then and software should be not
controlled and
behind balls it should be open-source
and intellectual property should be more
distributed and that was a the ethos of
the internet right it's kind of one of
the things that led to Wikipedia these
are amazing attributes of the millions
of people who worked on rebuilding the
entire tech stack for the internet
there's a question now is crypto that
and and certainly if you talk to many if
not most of the early developers working
on crypto related projects across the
whole gamut of crypto there is an ethos
there right of we do not trust middlemen
we do not trust banks we do not trust
governments we may not even trust the
media anymore and we need to find
software systems that enable people to
communicate where you can trust that
their goal there is no more middleman so
we can trust the communication is
authentic and we'd like to exchange
money or value or do transactions
without an untrustworthy middleman as
well and and we want to build that
architecture in a way so that your data
is your property and you can revoke it
at any time and it can't be amassed by a
single party anymore and though there's
an ethos there and that's a very
powerful ethos if it sticks like I mean
I think there are somewhere between tens
of thousands and hundreds of thousands
of software developers working in crypto
right now it changes many of them have
some piece of this ethos if not all of
it and that's gonna drive major change
if it holds so we're watching that
closely and that could be a wave that
would be a very big wave yeah so this
brings up a question that I think a lot
about I do not have the answer because I
don't even know if there is an answer
but it's this balance between society
believing something and the technology
being available to make it a reality
right and what I mean by that is it's
pretty well documented in you know these
pew surveys etc of the degradation of
trust in institutions institutions and
centralized
authorities right so yeah you see this
in the media government kind of a lot of
things you just named and that's not a
hey in the last two years that's
happened right I mean this has been
happening for a very very long period of
time and to me that overlaps very
interestingly to the internet right of
just
you know I used to believe everything
that I saw in television sets the only
source of information I had now all of a
sudden I got this other guy who's you
know my favorite video probably ever on
this is have you seen the weatherman and
he stayed yeah and I know it's like a
it's a clip of a weather guy and he's
standing in a parking lot and it's
raining hard and he's standing it looks
like the winds about a Blom over right
he's struggling just to stand there and
in the background there's these two
young kids and shorts and a t-shirt
combiner and they're just walking like
they're walking to their car after they
eat lunch right and again I get it right
you know it some people would argue that
television is entertainment right it's
not just news whatever but it's a
perfect example of like come on alright
and so over time this has happened but
could we ever do anything about it right
yes I trust this less and less but it's
still the best source right it's still
the only thing that I really have I
think the internet kind of started to
expose some of that but now really what
we're seeing is software engineers you
say wait a minute I can use all these
technologies that are available to me
and I can build something that can
actually give us a different solution
some argue it's better some argue it's
worse some you know pros cons whatever
but is that now just happening because
there's technology point in time that
makes it up possible or is it that
societal like shift and eat those where
people say no no this is really big
problem let's go focus on solving it I
think it's the latter but okay so it's
more the society component if you just
ask that the developers working on
decentralized technology why you doing
this
and the answer usually corresponds with
the decline in trust of institutions in
middle and many people who are really
excited about crypto come from Eastern
European states with highly distrust you
know untrustworthy governments and media
state-run media surveillance states or
people disappear and when you grew up
even some of your life in which I did
not but if you if you did you could
appreciate how your perspective and your
motivation to want to build technologies
that make it really hard for people to
surveil you to people disappear you to
have
your data and know who you are and where
you are you can see why that might be
something you want spend your time on
right and you believe the world might be
better with some of those things and
there's no surprise that encryption you
know is the basis for all this stuff so
I think that's a pretty powerful force
and I think you your observation that
Bitcoin effectively coincides its rise
coincides directly with the de PUE and
other data that shows a decline over 10
or 20 years in trust in institutions is
not an historical accident yeah let's um
sober up Bitcoin and loan the Sarah what
kind of crypto and the impact of that so
Bitcoin specifically the way I think
about it is it was the first real
application of a lot of these
technologies it's got this kind of
Immaculate Conception story right and
it's had this incredible rise in u.s.
dollar price how do you guys think about
it in terms of an investment opportunity
given that you've got a venture fund do
you guys do anything there and then also
how do you think it in more macro just
there's a piece of technology that could
have a big impact on the world but but
is that likely do you put kind of some
kind of handicap on it etc I think a few
thoughts but one with Bitcoin in
particular I appreciate many things
about it but two things in particular
one they solved a hard technology
problem a lot of clear sciences would
tell you you know we had Merkel trees
and there it wasn't a major innovation
but whether you call it major or minor
it has been around for a decade and has
been unhak t' unhak successfully and it
it solves a the problem of you know
single transaction no double spend and
distribute distributing trusts approach
on a transaction network there's a bunch
of improvements that can be made to it
for scalability the the way Theory I'm
looked at that and said well hang on we
can do more than just manage a ledger we
could actually execute code we'll call
them smart contracts but they really can
have logic to them and we can do that
decentralized and you can be sure that
it's secure that really blew us away and
was the moment when I read the theory
and whitepapers like wait a second this
is this is not just like some currency
for evading you know for drug dealers
like this is this is really significant
and and so that's informed my view of
how my little brain thinks a lot about
crypto there there are use cases related
to transactions whether that's store of
value or you know money and then there
are then there's an entirely different
opportunity around rebuilding the web
stack where applications and data are
decentralized which is as I said sort of
a fundamental shift to the way we
architect apps and I really think it's
important to talk about them separately
because in my mind I have to separate
them yeah because I think there are very
different investment thesis theses
arrive early yeah on the currency money
side do you guys do anything there or
are you more focused on the the latter
of kind of the computing platform and
the decent rows in the web yeah so well
personally I've been you know buying
crypto currencies for a while also
mining them I mined a Bitcoin very early
on just as an experiment when you could
still do that I mined crypto for two
years sorry I mind your theorem for two
years and a couple other coins as well
I've got a lot of spare GPU if anyone
wants to use them and normal networks
with them and and so I did that really
just to learn and you know personally
you know I've been an investor we chose
to do early on was to just try to get
smarter so we weren't smart enough here
there were other investors and
entrepreneurs who are way smarter than
we were who saw the opportunity earlier
than we did so we looked for partner and
what we found was this great group in
Brooklyn called coin fund who managed
really a venture fund there's a
combination of cryptocurrency that
largely is usually as illiquid at first
so they get involved very early in
projects that your protocol design and
digital economy design and and those
currencies eventually become liquid
and also equity investments but they're
sort of an early warning indicator for
us that really helped us or through the
thousands of crypto projects and a lot
of different dimensions and so we
invested in them and they're our partner
they've been very helpful partnerships
are very successful and they now have
multiple funds some are liquid only and
some are non liquid so I think we
participate that way that's one way and
separately we have made investments
ourselves as a fund in both in companies
that denominator they're valuing tokens
and companies that denominated in equity
Oh interesting so we are comfortable
doing both mm-hmm
and so when you think through the value
of the equity versus that took it's kind
of the value of cruel how do you guys
thought about this cuz I think this is
probably the biggest question I get from
the institutional world of institutional
investors realize something's happen to
make smart people looking at it working
on it I gotta do something they
understand equity right I make it an
investment it's gonna go public and get
acquired whatever there's also this
token accrual model where it kind of
looks like equity but sometimes it's not
sometimes it is right it just looks a
little different do you guys separate
those or do you look at it as there's
companies and products being built and
we'll do both and we frankly don't care
which one is which yeah I think I kind
of think of three actually we got equity
you have security token mm-hmm you have
utility - yep okay and the reason it's
important to separate that is the
security token is really trying to be a
proxy for equity ownership right it may
have different set of rights but and
it's either equity in a company or
equity in a piece of property right a
physical asset so there's a whole
category of people for the crypto focus
they can focus on you know a fractional
ownership of real estate or art or
sneakers or you know where you're taking
a physical real-world asset and you're
trying to fractionalize its ownership
into a liquid market and that otherwise
wasn't wasn't liquid we are fortunate
that our LPS allow us to take a broad
view we are used to having more than
just ownership in our companies but
having some rights that protect our
ownership and you often don't get much
of that if you're
security token as a proxy for equity
ownership so we tend to be I would say
even even in the crypto projects you
know the world really swung after 2017
and beginning 2018 a lot of projects
went back to raising venture capital and
the more traditional model so the
overwhelming majority of our crypto
holdings if you will are equity often
when we're buying a token there's an
equity right associated with it or it's
a combination so we're pretty flexible
but I just think that's where the market
is right now yeah absolutely
you uh you did an interview with my
fiance yeah he's a much better
interviewing in York absolutely she
gives me a hard time and critiques me
all the time she says I'm too nice to
people you are and one of the things
that you said in that interview that I
found really fascinating she asks you
about kind of crypto replacing vici or
competing with it and I think this was
more kind of token investing anyone in
the world can can participate and you
actually took the view of like we should
encourage this is a good thing maybe
talk a little bit about like how you
view something that I think most venture
capital would say wait a minute I'd like
our business write it we're pretty good
at this and we can make money why be so
kind of bullish on on the crypto
investing that that's been going well I
don't like gatekeepers I just think
they're endowed with an inauthentic
Authority right that somebody put them
in this position through a set of
fortunate circumstances and they are
making their best but usually arbitrary
decisions about whether allocating
capital or deciding who should be seen
in an art gallery or you know who should
what song should be played on the radio
or you know whatever I don't what what
books go on store shelves I just don't
like that I just think it's so
fundamentally unfair so we should try to
get rid of gatekeepers right and let
consumers decide what they want to
listen to watch et cetera give them a
lot of choice there are so VCS are
gatekeepers right we allocate capital to
the extent that you can get more funding
sources for entrepreneurs if we can get
more entrepreneurs to have more at-bats
at trying their next great thing I think
that's great that that'd be good that's
good for all of us it's entrepreneurship
drives economic growth wealth creation
makes jobs it's probably the most
important engine of our economy you want
more entrepreneurs
and why should be seized be a gating
factor for having more so I'd like there
to be alternate mechanisms for funding
Kickstarter and things like that some
have worked some haven't I think it
would take a long time to perfect so I'm
I'd like to see that the to the question
of like does it replace VCS I'm
skeptical of okay and as I think I think
they can coexist because I think that if
you look DC is a function has actually
was stood a lot of different change it's
been around for a long time I mean the
Laurance Rockefeller started doing this
type of investing in the 30s and then
Venrock you know more formally in the
60s and it hasn't changed all that much
right so there must be something about
him even in the face of a lot of
technology and market change humans
still seem to be decent at being an
allocator of selective capital and then
helping build those companies so I don't
leave we go away I will steal a little
bit of a Marc Andreessen answer to this
question where he's been asked this
before and he sort of says the nature of
company seems to be changing a little
bit right we've got on one extreme like
daos right and and on another extreme
you know just remote work or different
ways of building enterprises if that
changes a lot if they're token-based and
non-equity based you might have to have
a real change in the way capital
allocation is done and maybe VC has to
change a lot but if companies are still
mostly kind of what they are today
then it might not change yeah I mean
that's logical right of just companies
have been the same way for you know tens
of years and so capitalist doesn't
change this brings up the question I
guess of kind of competition in the
internet and I found online that you
many years ago did they testified around
this idea of competition in the internet
and I think that every soft and this
kind of resurfaces everyone wants to
debate kind of monopolies not monopolies
and centralization of data Ellis and
stuff but competition in venture capital
is pretty much dead to say now we're
seeing competition with the like average
investor right if I can just set up a
website accept funds from anyone in the
world
that's pretty competitive with venture
capital how do you think about the
internet and powering competition and
like how does that intersect with some
of things were seeing in crypto
the argument that the Internet Giants
have made around this is that our
competitors are one click away right
it's very easy to choose that might be
the best way I've heard their argument
summed up that's what they say the truth
is that data right is the monopolistic
fuel that empowers the sustained market
dominance so a lot of the Internet
giant's personally I love the products
of a lot of the Internet giant's so it's
kind of hard to hate them whereas like
you hate your telecom company because
like the service sucks right or you hate
the airline because they treat you like
you're cattle it's service still hard to
hate Google even though they're so
dominant because that website is awesome
the search engines great the email is
awesome thank you for YouTube so I think
we as consumers are lulled into our joy
in using the products but there still is
some market dysfunction that's happening
because of their large exclusive access
to our data and so I think that leads us
to crypto and one of the areas of crypto
that I've been fascinated by is can we
build not just a decentralized compute
architecture but a decentralized data
architecture so just in a small first
step we were talking earlier about the
Facebook and Twitter algorithms and how
they're machine learning algorithms are
deciding what we see well suppose I we
could all take our data which is like
our tweets and the things that we've
read and favored it and who we're
following and we can take that wherever
we want to whomever's algorithms we like
the most or reversed twitter could say
we'll just be the place where all the
data is living but anyone can plug it if
an algorithm in so if you don't like the
the tweet stream we're showing you let's
use some other people's stuff who might
not be so inclined to allow politically
manipulatable speech to appear in your
feed right Twitter seems to be Facebook
seems to really like putting that in
your feed and Twitter's
not so sure how they feel about it which
is sort of typical of everything about
Twitter so I think the you there are
other you as a consumer may choose
different algorithms write different
feeds and
can't do that today so there there's a
couple of different ways to re strike
the the dominance of the internet
platforms but the biggest way that
starts is if you have sort of revoke
ability of your data and you can take it
elsewhere and that is made possible and
it might decentralized architectures and
this is what excites me so much about
the decentralized web we invested in a
company called three-box ok so if you
try to write a decentralized application
adapt to things have to be really true
for that to be decentralized one is the
compute the code itself is run on a
network of computers not on like your
server sitting in AWS alright so it
could run on aetherium or any other
different layer one smart contract
platform and to the data that is exhaust
comes off from your use of it photos you
upload posts you write things that you
like your profile all the things that
Facebook Twitter extension would capture
yeah everything that they capture or
Google when I search for something and
click on a link all that data really
can't be stored on the server of the
application company that made the app it
has to be stored decentralized
throughout a web a decentralized web and
it needs to be revocable at any time you
need to say I'm taking my data back you
can't have it anymore I don't trust you
anymore I don't like you anymore the the
decentralized compute piece is being
worked on by a lot of layer one smart
contract platforms the data part which
is in many ways even more critical is
really a hard problem to solve as
developers so three bucks says we got
you
you just write to our API and we run a
decentralized data network and your data
gets stored in ipfs on an orbit database
and with our schema and we even will do
an identity layer on top of it and it's
all permissioned and you can be sure
that you're essentially compliant with a
decentralized architecture that to me is
really exciting because that enables the
decentralized to the centralization of
the mainstream platform so a couple of
questions about this one the name three
box is that because the data gets stored
in three boxes or a more type
mentality or is that a I think the three
is [ __ ] web three got it uh-huh and
because they're the data gets stored and
you know infinite number of places and
then in terms of if you have an
application I'm a user I access your
application you're using three box or
you can't see kind of all the data right
you're not capturing it what controls do
they have over my data yeah so first of
all the data is fully encrypted so no
one can see it
but people have you've awarded
permission to an application to be able
to use it not it and you can revoke that
permission so three bucks cannot see
your data they do know which
applications you have allowed to use it
and they will help manage the revoking
of that permission but they're really a
they're a friendly agent they're really
just an agent for you it really this is
or their operate a network of computable
they're not even their computers it's
like anyone can put a note on a network
just like you can spin up an aetherium
no to yourself anyone could spit up a
three box node and and be a participant
in the network and so they're really a
protocol does it you know they've really
created a protocol and a schema had a
bunch of software around that that in
itself is open sourced which is sort of
the ethos of yeah this raised an
interesting point I'm really interested
in kind of the increase in efficiency of
hardware and software that my family
comes out of the data center business
right and so there that business is
notorious for they got a lot of hardware
sitting around that's not being used and
they've got a Salesforce out trying to
sell it you know whatever all of a
sudden you get these whether it's you
know decentralized file storage right
three box what whatever it is you start
to build these marketplaces of well
what's my incentive to have my
Salesforce ghosts and sell this hardware
space our software what can I make from
that or there's persistent demand
through one of these decentralized
services if I just go ahead and point it
that way then there's revenue
opportunities and to me it feels like
old-school versus new-school a little
bit right and the companies that can
build those platforms or protocols that
facilitate the decentralized component
it just feels like a really big
opportunity that a lot of legacy players
don't see coming yeah I think one of the
things you're scratching out there is
that the many of these decentralized
protocols have an economic reward for
participating right so we call that
mining and in one parlance but other
people in different words for it but it
really means like contributing your
resources to a network whether they are
compute resources or storage resources
there should be economic motivation for
you to do that otherwise why would you
do it you have some material costs not
just the capex you bought the computer
hard drive with but the power it takes
to run it right and maybe the space your
pay you're paying to put it in and so
the reward for running it has to be
greater than those costs and and I think
there are some data centers who have a
bunch of spare hardware that have low
power costs who can do quite well just
adding their machinery to nodes but
there are a bunch that are in New Jersey
where you pay you know I don't know 16
cents a kilowatt hour and their profits
gonna be much lower than the 5 cent you
know maybe in upstate New York or so
there is some regionalization and other
environmental dependencies to make to
see whether it's a good business I think
what you're scratching at is if these
networks work people may be able to take
you know underutilized resources and
throw them into the network and that is
the efficiency of it is that we are well
you know the data center business with
virtualization came out it's like well
we bought a bunch of hardware but we
have this tiny little website running on
the blade server it's using 5% of the
load why are we doing that let's slice
it into 20 more websites and we'll share
the load right and so virtualization was
an efficiency play
I think decentralization is - got it one
other theme that you guys are investing
alongside is crypto collectables and
kind of n F T's digital collectables we
talked a little bit about what's the
excitement there and kind of what have
you guys done in that space so far yeah
what excites me in this space is again
it wasn't me who thought of it you know
like like all of us in 2017 I saw crypto
kitties come out and watched it explode
and break aetherium in that month and
and that kind of got me thinking what
you know I collected baseball cards as a
kid I saw my kids you know play with
pokemon cards they were just as big if
not bigger than baseball cards I started
looking into the size of collecting and
it's a massive market like humans do it
humans not all but many humans collect
something our shoes wine baseball cards
antiques there's and then I started
reading up on the psychology of
collecting why do humans collect and
there's the psychologists who have
documented like seven different reasons
why we do it and it's like a thing
humans do so it's really big well I like
to see pre-existing behavior as a a
proof point for why something can
succeed so collecting is big what we
don't really do is do is collect
anything digitally yet there's some
evidence we do like in-game items but
but those are centralized so and they
have it a fortnight fortnight yeah cape
or something but we can't it's very hard
to sell that it's so collecting and one
of the reason why we collect is like for
Besant reasons we want to hold it and
then profit from it later you can't
really sell the fort your fortnight
account you kind of can we have to do it
on eBay and you lose your account so you
can't really sell the items most of the
most valuable items in games are not
liquid you can't trade them outside the
game but what cryptic ad is what dapper
labs demonstrate it is you could build a
crypto collectible you could build a
digital collectible that has provenance
you know who owned it has authentication
it is real can have scarcity there is
only one and it can be traded
decentralized on exchanges everywhere so
wow I could buy a piece of digital item
or digital art I can know that I own it
the company who built it could go out of
business it still functions because the
code is totally decentralized running on
an open network and I can sell it later
or if it increases in value that to me
feels like that could unlock very large
digital collectible market it hasn't
happened it hasn't crossed over in the
mainstream but that's the thesis for our
investment in dapper labs and they are
trying to take what they built around
crypto keys and now do that with the NBA
they've announced a big partnership with
the NBA they're going to have a game
come this year that allows for moments
to be collected and those are there can
be rare ones and not rare ones and
you will know which ones you own and you
can use them in games themselves in the
way you use pokemon cards and games and
hopefully they'll go up in value and so
that's a pretty interesting experiment
I'm excited about there's one other area
that I'm not doing much in but I'm
watching which is the fractional as a
fractionalized ownership of physical
collectibles like would you take a great
painting and slice it into a thousand
tokens and you could sell the tokens and
those tokens are liquid or we're staring
out at a giant piece of real estate it's
not really a collectible but there are
people who would argue that we should
fractionalize real estate and other
large asset ownership and have them
trade on exchanges so it's a little bit
less about collecting but it is about
fractionalized ownership which also made
possible by crypto so this is really big
if it happens and we're watching it so
my last question before we get into the
rapid-fire to wrap up is is it happening
right kind of I like your way of talking
about AI crypto sisters like we're
looking for these waves right there's
early data points that say hey something
interesting is happening a lot of smart
people a lot of capital going into this
how do you evaluate for those that's
like hey is this real is this happening
is it a wave like what's your answer
yeah so I recently changed my mind a
little bit on this Oh interest I was of
the mind saying yeah the I need to see a
killer app be built by decentralized app
developers I'm looking for that moment
in the way that there was a killer
iPhone app that proved that mobile was a
thing and then it then it'll convince me
because this trading stuff is
speculation and I've been convinced that
that was the wrong way to look at it by
Tom Lee from funds trap who he says I'm
gonna get the numbers wrong because I
haven't looked at it in a couple weeks
but I believe he says a bit I'm gonna I
may have them in bursts but for every
barrel of oil that is used in consumed
in transportation so like burned right
it's traded 16 times for every one time
that it's bought interesting and for
every dollar US dollar that is used in a
transaction its traded 30 times
Wow now I may have them reverse I think
the numbers are 16 to 30 I'm sorry Tama
from getting it wrong buddy I'm giving
you free but the whole idea is there's a
lot more financial transaction yeah is
the super set it is the killer app
actually and it precedes demonstration
of other applications so now I don't
believe that in order for crypto to be
big there needs to be mainstream non
speculation use cases and I think they
may come but I think that speculation is
a killer app and what's nice about that
is that is the behavior that's happening
right now right and in in big numbers
right it I mean it's very small compared
to other asset classes but millions of
people write hundreds of thousands to
millions depending on the chain so I
think that is reorient a little and and
the investors who are smarter than I was
who bet on let's call it trading
infrastructure custody while it's all
the things you need to enable
speculation are gonna do just fine and
not every one of the companies will
succeed but that infrastructure has to
exist if what that means is you know 16
to 30 X the volume will be in
speculation than is in transactions more
other uses and then it was a really
smart bet of theirs so I think the
answer is it is here the question is how
much bigger does it get and what other
use cases emerge and where do you invest
and so there I'm trying to be a realist
I'm like show me the money right or just
show me evidence the evidence I see is
developer demand which is what led to
the three box investment you know
they've had more than 20 or 30,000
download and install so our three box
that's really big it's really big right
like might even be higher than that
right now
you know they hunt hundreds a week
sometimes hundreds a day if it's around
eath Berlin or even Denver and and they
are clearly dominating this use case so
that's an early warning indicator that
there are devs who are building apps
taps and need to solve decentralized
data so that's the type of indicators
we're looking for got it
rapid-fire questions what uh what's the
most important company in all of crypto
in your opinion
most important or I mean I just admire
coinbase
they're just run so well they're solving
a real customer problem they do it
elegantly there were a user centric I'm
not of the crypto mind that you can
never have someone manage your keys
centralized although I appreciate why
you may not want to but I think they're
really a company to watch just there
executions awesome so exchanges are by
far the most popular answer that
question and I don't yet know what to
make of when that popular answer changes
right if people start saying something
other than exchanges does that mean the
way people are interacting with the
assets is changing is it some you know
signal something in the market or
whatever but I've been asking that
question for almost a year someone says
financier yeah it's just exchanges and
and so uh it's it'll be interesting when
it changes how they don't tell us that's
absolutely what's the one law regulation
that you would change or improve kind of
related to crypto if you could yeah
there's a lot but the one I would change
right away is that companies who follow
the sort of reg D approach to to
effectively listing a coin should be
allowed to have them trade on exchanges
in the US and that's not possible yet so
basically just keep the Reg D rules but
change what happens if you follow those
rules
it's very least you should if you went
reg D you should be rewarded by your
token being able to be liquid and
they're not letting that happen in the
US but I would change so many other
things about the way the SE C's approach
this for sure what do you think your
most controversial thought in crypto is
so something that you believe is true
but most people will disagree with you
on well what's I think actually still if
you look broadly at tech being pro
crypto is controversial right right like
being that this really is something big
is non consensus today yeah it almost
feels like pre like second half
seventeen a lot of heroes like I don't
know what this thing is whatever then
second half seventeen also people like
wait a minute
like did I miss it right or am I making
a mistake and then it was like they all
got suckered right and the price crashes
and now everyone's like all that thing's
written off
yes I think the hard question answer
right and so it helped he asked me what
is the advantage of building a DAP Moser
answer well so like the because in 1995
a few said well what's the advantage of
doing things on the web like why it's
like let me count the ways man I mean
like you get it instantly and there's no
middleman and right the global cost of
publishing it like I'm but yeah no
trucks better the environment like I it
with too many answers why should you use
a DAP because it's slower and and they
get super super clunky and the thing you
got to do with your mowett with the UM
with the wallet and half away yeah like
not good answers so but the the answer
is a developer friendly answer today
right it's because you can trust the
platform they won't revoke it later but
that's not a that won't work that
doesn't answer the pew question of why
are you using adapt and yeah but I'll
push back on that right like you still
had dial-up internet right so like hey
the newspaper gets delivered to my door
or like I can take up my phone line and
dial up to the Internet to read the news
like there's some comparisons I don't
know if it's quite as clear but but I
think there was still some user
experience of it that wasn't as good yes
so so in the answer of why will you
tolerate the inconveniences there's no
us to be a good thing you're getting out
of it and I think with crypto
collectibles it's like well I have a
digital good that is going up in value
or may not but I can play use it in
games and I'm trading it in collecting
it so there's a real answer like for why
did you tolerate the meta mask
brain-dead Ness to buy your crypto kitty
and I think you know dapper wants to
make sure there is no brain deadness
when you buy your NBA moments hmm
so I think we'll have a good answer then
but you know why would you build you
wouldn't build a word processor today
right decentralized and the consumer
would not walk away from that experience
to say well that's better than using
word or Google Docs right it's not it's
slower and why and the benefit wouldn't
be clear but when you can say Google
doesn't have my data that's what that
was my benefit like I now I'm off to
worry about my photos leaking to someone
else because they're encrypted in
decentralized I think that will be a
user benefit yeah
makes sense what's the most important
book you've ever read there's so many
probably sapiens really helped me think
longer term that there's somewhat of an
inevitable arc enlightenment now by
Pinker made me get a little bit less
depressed that you know that the arc of
justice bends you know the arc of
history bends towards justice and that
like things are getting better that if
you look over long term in the last year
I've just switched from reading I'm
basically only reading text books
science texts I'm just really I'm just
so annoyed by the fact that I can't
trust any source anymore yeah being
manipulated by everything that I'm just
going to science textbooks I've been
reading about electromagnetic you know
RF actually the problem we were talking
about earlier about why does do we get
bad cell coverage here on the 54th floor
yep I've been reading about that really
yeah what uh what's the main takeaway
like it like as you consume what I'll
call more dense scientific content is it
non disputable information it depends on
what's the in uh what is it in Texas
there was a yes I'm not reading any
Texas no no but uh is it because you
want to learn about that one specific
it's just fact its pleasant to read fat
yeah and no dispute about it and like
I'm learning and it's I'm getting
smarter about something and I don't have
to worry about it's the opinion of
someone for sure I wrap up by letting
you ask me a question but first we talk
about aliens and given your you're bent
on the scientific textbooks you think
they're real you believe there's no
proof of extraterrestrial life
that's far so agreed but do I think that
will change yes well I'm not sure where
I am on the Fermi paradox but by the
numbers you know the number of places
where life could exist feels like there
should be life out there
yeah but caveated with the Fermi paradox
so here's the the two things
that blow my mind right so I recently
watched an explained series on Netflix
they have about basically intelligent
life outside of Earth right there they
don't use the term aliens which I think
was intentional to make it more
legitimate um
they claim that there's for every one
grain of sand on earth there are ten
thousand planets out there right and
just like to even try to affect you know
we really said make ten thousand planets
hardness and incredible the second thing
is I think a lot about the comparison
between space and the ocean right and
and there's some accounts that I found
on Instagram and Twitter and stuff where
they basically show things in the ocean
that you when you look at you can't see
right now you just don't know what they
are right you've never seen this before
and it just reminds me I'm like we know
so little about our own oceans let alone
what's out there in space and so it
comes down to like this mathematical
probability but to me the part that I
think shocked me as I've asked this
question many times is everyone looks up
they look out right that they want to
know what's out there how many people
are actually interested in the ocean how
many people are interested in what's
going on in here in earth and there's
not that many people mm-hmm and we but
we don't discover like twenty new
species a year just by going down on the
ocean yeah crazy there's a guy so my one
of the podcast episodes I want to record
is there's a Brazilian billionaire who
he's built the it's a one-man submarine
basically right so kind of a capsule
that is built to go to the depths of the
ocean and he has visited now I think
it's two or three of the oceans deepest
point so he's you know Indian Ocean
whatever and you see him amazing this
little thing right and you know rich guy
so I got all the things he could be
doing but it's fascinating because he's
the first person to do it right and
you're like look like oceans right there
right and and to see people kind of just
now exploring is cool and and my
question for him is gonna be why are you
in there
right you know it's kind of like hey
there's a lot of people I could just not
find anyone else or are you actually
that personally interested yeah well
we'll see okay I get to ask you a
question
you
you've done 220 of these something like
that yeah 220 221 something like that
what is the one thing you've heard that
was the most controversial at the time -
you were like there's no way that's true
that's proven to be right well that's
proven to be right all right before I
answer that I just got a funny one for
you said I don't know if you know Josh
Brown from RIT's whole wolf management
it's a basically wolf man it's like
financial advisor he came in here he was
maybe one of the first 50 interviews and
he was very early when I started asking
the alien question and he said to me
without blinking he said I believe that
ghosts are more real than aliens and I
remember thinking like that's blasphemy
but but that always sticks out in my
mind I would say the thing that somebody
has said that I didn't agree with it
ended up being true
[Music]
this is recency bias but we have a guy
mark Schneider come in who nuclear
engineer and one of the things that he
really explained was a lot of the causes
for the you know chair Nobel Fukushima
etc how much of it was human error right
compared to more like technology or just
actual nuclear so kind of as I looked at
that that was pretty eye-opening
and then another thing that I think has
been pretty interesting is it's not so
much there was controversial when he
said it but a Jim o Shaughnessy when he
came in he spent a lot of time talking
about just like look I don't know but
that's how I look at every market right
I'm a quant it's like I don't really
start stocks I don't know the history
Bitcoin or any of this stuff and he's
really like spent a lot of time both
publicly and helping me see like humans
really really buys right and like we
think we're so smart and we know nothing
and it was backed up I read two books
you probably read them super forecasters
and then algorithms to live by I think
it's not work and both them they hit on
some more things right it's just like we
know nothing
and I think when you take that
perspective at a lot of this all of a
sudden you turn into more like curious I
want to receive the information rather
than like I know how the world's gonna
move and let me go invest in Burke says
In God We Trust everyone else bring data
I've never heard that that's pretty good
all right listen where can people find
you on the Internet yeah Ben Rock follow
me on Twitter at Pakman PA que ma n DM
me talk to me also find me on the Van
Rock website reach out anytime let me
know if you're working on something
great awesome
I really preciate coming to do this
great honor to be here this is a high
one of the more fun conversations I've
had hey yes polina you said that yeah
she will she'll think you're lying but I
appreciate very much yeah thanks for
having me here I appreciate it